à sète saline dans les années 50-60
qu'est-ce qu'elle évoquait pour vous
dans votre jeunesse
un terrain de jeu un grand terrain de
jeu en fait le maire d'arc et senans
jacques morrison sculpteur bernard jobin
ont connu la saline en friche à
l'abandon dans les années 50 et 60
on était encore loin de la mise en
lumière de ce haut lieu du patrimoine
mondial et on s'appropriait même
certains des bâtiments par exemple moi
je sais que je lisais la maison du
directeur
c'est la mienne
[Musique]
espace de jeux espièglerie les enfants
escaladaient les murs pour y chercher
une part de rêve matinée de mystère
c'est un bâtiment inquiétant en quelque
sorte inquiétant parce que la végétation
avait commencé à prendre
oui même elle avait pris beaucoup le
dessus c'est à dire que les colonies où
les façades était gagné par l'ailière et
les murs alors nous enfants c'était
extraordinaire
sur cet hémicycle ce succès des
bâtiments qui épouse la courbe bâtiments
nécessaires à une agglomération
industriel logement des ouvriers
ateliers les charpentiers des tonneliers
et des forgerons l'activité de la ville
de show était tout entière vouée au sel
durant toutes ces années de mise entre
parenthèses des habitants d'arc et
senans ont investi ce lieu historique
pour y cultiver leurs petits jardins les
jardins étaient certainement délimiter
mais c'était surtout sur la pelouse
conquis se trouve qu'il trouve ici à ma
droite là les gens me demandaient
l'autorisation et venez faire un morceau
de jardin 30 ou 40 mètres carrés de
jardin et puis se retrouver là dans
cette partie d'un la saline abritait les
jardins des adultes les courses de vélo
des enfants dans le bâtiment des selles
et même quelques logements
la petite histoire a rejoint la grande
ces photos
vous savez c'est le grand chose
en 1966 bernard jobin étudiant à l'école
des beaux-arts consacre sa thèse au
saline d'arc-et-senans car on disait les
salines l'idée de cette thèse c'était
découvrir l'aspect sculpturale dans
cette architecture
donc il ya des éléments qui sont
extrêmement intéressant par exemple des
colonies son appel de l'école bégaie et
puis les travaux ont commencé et l'idée
d'une nouvelle vie pour la saline a fait
son chemin petit à petit ce sas éclairer
sa s'éclairait au point que l'
architecture devenait autre chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où sommes nous ici nous sommes nous
sommes pas au xviiie siècle mais déjà au
xxème siècle pour essayer de préparer le
21e dans les salines de choc était une
usine de sun au xviiie siècle
si la saline royale d'arc isner n'avait
jamais été remise en lumière et remise
en état
on peut l'imaginer c'est possible mais
alors ce je pense aurait été une
catastrophe
vous pourrez faire sa une aujourd'hui
totalement totalement
on est très fiers de notre monument
[Musique]